spring is fast approaching which means
spring watering restrictions will be in
play the Southern Nevada Water Authority
the sponsors of this next segment are
here to help J.C Fernandez visited
Springs Preserve for more information
[Music]
well welcome to the beautiful Springs
preserves and let's introduce this is
Corey he's with the Southern Nevada
Water Authority it's good to see you
everybody good to see you too man thanks
for having me here today you know
technically even though it is still
winter right now the spring watering
restrictions are in place what does that
mean as the calendar moves from Winter
to spring it gives us the opportunity to
ramp up and start to water on our three
assigned watering days but just because
you can water on those three Assad
watering days doesn't mean that you have
to you should be kind of active when it
comes to your sprinkler system and your
irrigation system because right now
winter time it was one day a week spring
rolls in we can expand it more but
recently we've been getting a lot of
rain so if you're getting rain you
should turn things off right active is
the perfect word pay attention to the
temperature pay attention to the amount
of precipitation that we're getting
we've had it inordinately wet
um winter so I've turned off my
irrigation and it'll stay off into the
amount of precipitation that we got over
the past last week in the past couple of
weeks so you need to pay attention to
the weather which will help things out
overall and when it does come to
Springtime I think plants and I think
trees and flowers are there any tips
when it comes to watering them not
everything needs the same amount of
irrigation your plants and your trees
need much less irrigation than your
grass as a matter of fact your plants
and trees only typically need to be
watered about one or two days a week for
grass
12 about 12 minutes a day is really all
you need okay let's talk about grass and
incentives that you have because then
you want people to see remove the grass
put the nice Stone landscaping in what
are some incentives that you guys offer
we offered three dollars a square foot
to remove that grass and put in three
dollars a square foot that's great to
remove grass and put in water smart
landscape so it not only saves you money
as you install it but your water bill in
the future goes down significantly by
having that drip irrigation as opposed
to that spray irrigation that you would
have for grass I feel like a lot of the
older homes have big grassy yards
someone's watching right now they just
moved into that older home they want to
make that change they go to the website
to get more information go to snwa.com
and learn about our water smart
Landscapes program Corey one thing I've
heard people talking about do I have to
write a smart irrigation controller do I
have that right and what is it you're
right a smart irrigation controller what
it will do is it will pay attention so
you don't have to if it's raining
outside or snowing outside it'll
automatically shut off so the irrigation
isn't taking place it's a lot smarter
than you or I and since the temperatures
we have rebates that will give you money
to put in and install a smart irrigation
controller okay someone's watching right
now and speaking of myself you see
someone in your neighborhood where
they're I mean they're abusing the water
privileges or maybe they have that
busted sprinkler head that they're not
fixing who who do you tell you can go to
snwa.com if you have the the app on your
phone you can report it report it there
our goal is to be communicative and not
necessarily punitive a lot of people
because we up water early in the morning
or late at night we may not know that we
have a malfunction on our property so
you can call the Southern Nevada Water
Authority or the Las Vegas Valley Water
District whoever your water service
provider is you can call them and we'll
come out and investigate and see what it
is that's going on since Springtime
water and restrictions are in play when
does summer kick in by the way may may
we'll come back for that one absolutely
Corey thank you so much appreciate thank
you very much and water smart
thank you to the Southern Nevada Water
Authority for sponsoring this segment
call
702-258 save or visit
snwa.com for more information